[Music]
facial hey the try guys are giving and
giving each other facial in there really
working it but I've also never had a
facial I'm excited when you're giving a
facial there's somebody getting it thank
you Dougy and we're gonna give it
because we're good at giving it is it
coming out Oh am i doing but you're
gonna get Zack you have a hot nose thank
you and I get lovely keep Yugi
please touch my face we
my name is Katie I'm an esthetician at
face house in Studio City and I've been
doing this for four years an
aesthetician is a skin care professional
she's gonna teach us how to rub cream on
each other poke each other in the face
did you stuff a couple hands dry guys
are giving each other facials it's been
a long time coming
it's been a long time coming any joke
you have about facials got to make sure
those blue balls are wet I scored it a
bit it's my first time I've heard it
every esthetician has her debts pressure
hi there Katie hello so I'm very excited
for my first facial let's talk about
your skin it's very sensitive my face is
full of gunk and my nose just squirts
out white goo like crazy done it looks
like you have a little bit of an oilier
skin type so I think we're probably
gonna do a general and facial on you but
we're gonna go wider on the enzyme as
you'll see in a moment I have beautiful
skin flawless I might say got some
blackheads on the nose no I don't I
think we should do a blueberry detox
peel on you that sounds yummy
both facials that Zach and Keith are
gonna be doing our facials I do every
single day and most people can handle
them who are you we're gonna be kind of
gentle to me right yes are you ready for
special facial treatment what is going
on with you the nose is almost like the
penis of the face okay I don't know what
that means even though our gonna be
together we're gonna do a gentler facial
and with Zach I'm gonna beat that face
out what am i blindfolding him like 50
shades style where am i have an tiem
Karate Kid style do I need to wash my
hands first you should probably wash
your hands
relax Oh lady at the spa oh my god do I
look cute yeah it's late a spa okay so
because he is a bit on the drier side
cuz he doesn't do anything to his skin
thank you we got it thank you
we're gonna do a creamy cleanser that's
gonna hydrate the skin does you have dry
skin and you know it's like a strawberry
because it's leaving seeds everywhere
I'd like to pause fruit it's a fan I'm
gonna get exfoliated it's gonna be
moisturized you're a lazy eye your eyes
are very uneven we never want the client
to ever feel bad about themselves well
ours the next step we're actually gonna
enzyme him but it's professional
strength so you have to have a light
sense to do it she's gonna [ __ ] you up
beautiful skin and smooth smooth faces
that was in Keith's kit no that's not
true that's not true
you're gonna feel like you have a mild
sunburn you might feel some pulsation in
your skin cuz all the blood is flowing
it's cool so my hands are also cold yeah
it's good about to be very warm oh
that's a threat come on I'll lick his
face right now I would suggest not doing
that Kenny well can you do that will it
burn his tongue hi
yeah yeah no it's really sour it's
professional strike it kind of feels
like I'm underwater if I kiss you in the
fort I'm gonna ruin your facial yeah
you're right you'd probably kiss me on
the lips I'm gonna go change my water
you're gonna sit with this for a couple
minutes
where you going go with me fine I
promise
okay you're in good hands I don't oh
wait my face is getting like just
tighter it's like someone's like taking
the skin and just like this pulling it
as far as they can spread your feet
hi Katie walking back so I noticed that
my face is burning a lot yeah being told
by my friend it's red this is it what
it's supposed to do
let's see what I look like Keith you let
them do this to me I was on my phone at
the time does this mean what I think it
means it's time it's time to extract
extractions are a thing on the internet
people love pimple popping videos and I
think that [ __ ] is gross
and oh you jack
it's okay no it's part of it oh sorry
you're pinching me
yeah
oh yeah
that's it pretty anticlimactic man keeps
nose was [ __ ] compared to yours we are
gonna do a strawberry rhubarb mass oh I
am your canvas it's all over me I will
so now at this point we're going to let
him relax with his mask on and we're
gonna do some cool globes so this is
high frequency you're gonna feel a
little zing
Oh
so we can do some facial massage - you
have - yes he does so now we're gonna do
a moisturizer mmm just rub you out this
endings making me real happy you know
it's a real happy ending we could do an
affirmation you are loved
it's like it was all worth it you know
mrs. fummer is one lucky cow I got new
clients coming in you get out of here
buddy yeah
see you next time don't forget to leave
me a review on Yelp this has been the
try guys try facials or at least half of
us you're gonna do the thumb screaming
oh we're not done yet
so I did I give you a good facial yeah
you give a great facial are you GE me a
facial in Italy
I want to thank Katie she was great I
want to tell Ned to go to hell he was a
demon now it is ready it rises it is
my basal Gration now go kill monster
this is lavender essential Oreo
take a deep breath in you're beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
he died as he lived happy beautiful you
can remove the headband